disney according to the new york times
wants the robots in its parks i'm
reading a tweet here to come alive one
goal setting them free from the confines
of the rides and letting them wander
walkways to turn the parks into as one
executive put it inhabited places the
article covers how disney's secretive r
d division called imagineering is
building ai robotics that model some of
the brand's most popular characters
so a buzz lightyear that walks around
hopefully not with a real ray gun is
pretty interesting according to the
article one of disney senior robotics
experts scott lavalley came from boston
dynamics while at boston dynamics
lavalier contributed to an early version
of atlas which is the robot you just saw
doing parkour so from the same article
uh in the new york times disney said it
has no plans to replace human performers
winnie the pooh cruella deville peter
pan princess jasmine and other beloved
walk-around characters will continue to
be played by people wearing costumes
instead disney's new focus on robotics
will bring extreme marvel and star wars
characters to life the article uses the
hulk baby yoda and a swinging spider-man
as examples i would put into that also
r2d2 that would be a layup maybe since
they owned pixar wally would be a layup
there's a lot of characters they could
do that are not human and that would be
a stormtrooper comes to mind although
that's quite terrorizing but would be a
layup for the folks over at boston
dynamics in fact
stormtroopers are not as dexterous
in star wars as those boston dynamics
robots are so they're a little
overqualified for the job the article
also references disney's project kiwi
in which they created a fully
animatronic groot if you remember the
marvel character from guardians of the
galaxy who would say i am groot if
you're on youtube you can actually see
the groot which we're playing uh in the
background here it is amazing it's a bit
terrorizing it reminds me of chucky from
the child's play series and uh the
interesting thing about disney's robot
is it's not just root according to the
article the groot robot is a prototype
for small scale free roaming robot
actors that can take on the role of any
similarly sized disney character in
other words disney does not want a
one-off they're going to do this across
all of their character lines so snow
white might be real the seven dwarfs
could be robots obviously just like the
actors and actresses can change
wardrobes disney's ai robots will be
able to take on new identities movements
and reactions at the push of a button
here's the quote cameras and sensors
will give these robots the ability to
make on the flight choices about what to
do and say custom software allows
animators and engineers to design
behaviors happy sad sneaky and convey
emotions maybe they'll act differently
towards
a four-year-old that a 40-year-old would
be what i would think they could tell
the eye level how tall you are maybe
they'll even be able to tell how old you
are because there's a website right now
where you can go and it guesses your age
pretty pretty accurately leslie evans
the senior engineering executive told
the new york times the following and all
this technology must disappear which
takes a crazy amount of engineering just
like the michael crichton novel
westworld which became a movie which
became a great hbo series we don't want
anyone thinking that's the most
sophisticated robot i ever encountered
it has to be look it's groot i think
she's right about that that's a that's a
plain english way of saying that these
must
pass through the uncanny valley if you
don't know on county valley you can just
look it up on wikipedia when's it going
to be available project kiwi has to
advance to a play test stage which is a
short low profile dry run at a theme
park to gather guest feedback
disney declined to tell the new york
times when or where this test would
occur
later in the article the author reveals
that disney imagineering's team are also
working on a full body exoskeletons for
massive characters like the hulk and
thana or what looks like to be a wampa
of a yeti from star wars if you remember
that rips luke's face when luke is on
hoth and then he gets saved by
uh han solo who cuts open a tauntaun and
says uh this doesn't smell great but it
will keep you warm and then proceeds to
shove
luke skywalker into the guts of the
taunt but of course luke's that's not
before luke skywalker has a vision and
sees obi-wan who tells them you will go
to dagobah to trade with master yoda
i've seen the empire strikes back no
less than a hundred times
one place where disney could utilize
their new robots is the galactic star
cruiser disney's new fully immersible
star wars experience which is supposed
to mimic a cruise ship in space this
fully immersible hotel will open in
spring of 2022. according to an article
by cnn the hotel experience is a
multi-day journey with entertainment
food and beverages included i really
want to do this for my kids it is
amazing looking and there seems to be
story points so you can make a decision
with your group and you know then go
through almost like it's a choose your
own adventure uh there's a term for this
uh where people do this in person like
nerds and they get together at hotels
and they do like little conventions
where they act like characters and
there's some storyline it's like real
world dungeons and dragons i think it's
called larping
live-action role-playing anyway it's for
nerds and now disney's gonna mainstream
it so cultural appropriation by disney
from the nerds in
is happening the prices are bonkers a
two-night stay is forty eight hundred
dollars for two guests in a cabin
uh fifty three hundred for three guests
six thousand dollars for guests which
are like what i'm paying so basically
six thousand dollars for a family of
four for two nights that is bonkers um
that is ridiculously expensive and i
think that's not cool by disney i think
disney should look at this and maybe
reconsider that kind of exclusionary
pricing i don't think it's very good for
their brand that would be per post
person like fifteen hundred dollars
staying at a hotel and eating meals for
middle class family going to disney
would probably be
i don't know
fifteen hundred dollars you'd probably
be 25 of that i think disney's making a
huge mistake here with this if i was
running disney i would look at this and
say we'll make it a loss leader until we
can't or just break even on it and maybe
explain that to the public but that
price gouging is just actually gross
i'll be honest and as i said it's going
to be this like choice dependent
experience so you get to make some light
side dark side consequences etc it's
wildly overpriced i'm totally going to
do it i don't like the pricing i'd
rather they charge less i don't know if
there's any way for them to
do
you know it's interesting their brand is
supposed to be accessible
and um this kind of goes against
everybody in the world being able to
afford to go to disney so i don't like
it i do robots though i think the robots
are gonna be awesome
healthy and happy employees create
successful companies that's a fact and
com for business can help your employees
be their best selves at work don't i
know it i was one of the early investors
in com you can partner with the number
one mental fitness app to provide
support and tools for your employees
right now com can help kick start mental
well-being initiatives by empowering
employees to stress less
and to rest better and finally build
resilience and that's what you need
because work is hard and you're going to
get curveballs that are going to get
thrown at you and you don't want to
freak out you want to be calm so they
have an entire library of content
specifically designed for the workplace
it includes lo-fi music playlists
quick breathing breaks guided
meditations and hundreds of soothing
sleep stories which not only do i use it
with my kids and it works brilliantly
they even have programs tailored for
mental health and productivity like
their mindfulness at work series which
is excellent millions of employees at
over 600 companies like lincoln iterable
and universal studios use com for
business today and your employees are
going to feel so cared for when you give
them this that's the great part about it
com is offering a free well-being ebook
for hr and benefit leaders and one month
three after you attend a free demo at
com.com twist that's right you get the
free ebook and one month free just gotta
attend the demo and see what it's all
about com.com twist again c-a-l-m-com
what a dominion com.com
twist